you've not heard a lot about how to
search for good hyper parameters before
wrapping up our discussion on hyper
parameter search I want to share with
you just a couple final tips and tricks
for how to organize your hyper Frances
search process deep learning today is
applied to many different application
areas and that intuitions about hyper
parameter settings from one application
area may or may not transfer to a
different one there is a lot of
cross-fertilization
a lot of different applications domain
so for example I've seen ideas 2000 the
computer vision community such as
confidence or res Nets which we'll talk
about in a later course successfully
apply to speech and I've seen ideas that
were first developed in speech
successfully applied in NLP and so on so
one nice development in deep learning is
that people from different application
domains do read increasingly research
papers from other application domains to
look for inspiration for cross
fertilization in terms of your setting
for the hyper parameters though I've
seen that intuitions do get fail so even
if you work on just one problem
say logistics you might have found a
good setting for the hyper parameters
and kept on developing your algorithm or
maybe seen your data
gradually change over the course of
several months or maybe just upgraded
the servers in your data center and
because of those changes the best
setting of your hyper parameters can get
stale so I recommend maybe just re
testing or reevaluating your hyper
parameters at least once every several
months to make sure that you're still
happy with the values you have finally
in terms of how people go about
searching for hyper parameters I see
maybe two major schools of thought or
maybe two major different ways in which
people go about it one way is if you
babysit one model and usually you do
this if you have maybe a huge data set
but not a lot of computational resources
not allow CPUs and GPUs so you can
basically afford to Train only one model
or a very small number of bottles at a
time in that case you might gradually
babysit that model even as its trained
so for example on day zero you might
initialize the parameters random and
then start training and you gradually
watch you know your learning curve may
be the cost function J or your death set
error or something else gradually
decrease over the first day then at the
end of day one you might say gee looks
looks learn quite well I'm going to try
increasing the learning rate robits and
see how it does and then maybe does
better and then bless your day to
performance and after 2 days you say ok
still doing quite well maybe after the
momentum term a bit or decrease of
learning regular bit now and then you
know in two days three and every day you
kind of look at it and you know try
edging up and down your parameters and
maybe on one day you found your learning
rate was too big so you might go back to
the previous days model and so on you're
kind of babysitting the model one day at
a time even as a training over a course
of many days or over the course of
several different weeks so that's one
approach and people that babysit one
model that is watching a performance and
you know patiently nudging the learning
rate up or down that's usually what
happens if you don't have enough
computational capacity to train a lot of
models at the same time the other
approach would be if you train many
models in parallel so you might have
some setting of the hyper browsers and
just let it run by itself either for a
day or even for multiple days and then
give some learning curve like that and
this could be a plot of the cost
function J or cost of your training
error or cause you're just an error but
some measures in your tracking and then
at the same time you might start up a
different model with a different setting
on the high preferences and so your
second model might generate a different
learning curve maybe one that looks like
that looks like that one looks better
and at the same time you might train a
third model which my genuine learning
curve does all that and another one that
maybe this one diverges that looks like
that and so on but you might train many
different models in parallel where these
orange lines are different models right
then so this way you can try a lot of
different hyper parameter settings and
then just maybe quickly at the end
pick the one that works best look like
in this example it was
maybe describe their little pest so to
make an analogy I'm going to call the
approach on the left the pander approach
you know when pandas have children they
have very few children usually one child
at a time and then they really put a lot
of effort into making sure that the baby
pandas device so that's really
babysitting you know one model or one
baby panda words the personal rate is
more like what fish do and commonly
called it the caviar strategy there's
some fish that lay over a hundred
million eggs in one season in one mating
season but the way fish reproduces they
lay a lot of eggs and don't pay too much
attention to any one of them but you
know just see that hopefully one of them
or maybe a bunch of them will do well so
I guess this is really the difference
between how mammals reproduce versus how
fish and a lot of reptiles reproduce but
I'm going to call it the pander approach
versus the caviar approach since there's
more fun and memorable so the way to
choose between these two approaches is
really a function of how much
computational resources you have if you
have enough computers they train a lot
of models in parallel then by all means
take the caviar approach and try a lot
of different Hydra parameters and see
what worlds but in some application
domains I see this in some online
advertising settings as well as in some
computer vision applications where
there's just so much data and the models
you want to train are so big that's
difficult to train a lot of models at
the same time it's really application
dependent of course that are but I've
seen those communities use the Pandora
approach a little bit more where you are
kind of babying a single model long and
nudging the parameters up and down and
trying to make this one model you know
work although of course you know the
Pandora approach having trained one
model and seeing it work or not work
maybe in the second week of the third
week maybe you actually initialize a
different model and then you know baby
that went along just like even pandas I
guess can have multiple children in
their lifetime even if they have only
one or a very small number of children
at any one time so hopefully this gives
you a good sense of how to go about the
hyper parameter search process
now it turns out that there's one other
technique that can make your neural
network much more robust to the choice
of hyper parameters
doesn't work for all neural networks but
when it does it can make the hyper
parent to search much easier and also
make training go much faster let's talk
about this technique in the next video